well the midterm elections are just 26
days so now kind of amazing too much
going on to digest so as we move closer
to Election Day we're going to take a
closer look at particular races in the
candidates running in them tonight we
want to tell you about
Kyrsten Sinema she's running as a
Democrat to replace Jeff Flake in the US
Senate in Arizona
illegal immigration has long been an
important issue in that state which
shares a long and largely undefended
border with Mexico cinema in this race
has tried to portray herself as a
moderate on that question someone who
supports both amnesty for illegal aliens
but also more robust border security
there was growing evidence though that
she is not a moderate at least by
American standards in 2006 cinema
declared that illegal aliens who died
trying to sneak into our country are
morally equivalent to Americans dying in
the Iraq war here's part of the quote to
state that immigration is not a war or
is not equal in magnitude to war I
believe dishonours those who have died
in this country and others as migrants
the deaths that people suffer in the
Mexico Arizona desert are the same as
the deaths that people suffer in the
Iraq desert they are needless senseless
deaths that's not a mainstream position
even now in the middle of the revolution
or going through three years after she
said that cinema described her position
on immigration laws this way quote I
oppose all of them so if you think that
foreigners breaking your country's laws
are every bit as good as the citizens
dying to defend them it's possible you
may have a problem with your own people
your own countrymen the citizens of your
nation and cinema seat certainly seems
to have a problem with them here she is
in 2011 but the past several years was
having Arizona and be like
no Charlie hurt is the opinion editor at
The Washington Times at a very smart man
if we can say joins us tonight
Charlie things have changed so much that
this is not disqualifying saying that
the deaths of illegal aliens in the
desert trying to break our laws are
morally equivalent to the deaths of our
soldiers fighting in Iraq three years
ago would have been over does this hurt
her at all do you think I certainly hope
it does but you raised a very good point
and what we've seen you know everybody
talks about that what the tea party has
done to the Republican Party and I think
there was some very healthy stuff there
in terms of forcing Republicans to sort
of get back to some of their principles
but my goodness what we're seeing
happened to the Democratic Party a once
legitimate party that yes that we relied
on to keep the Republicans honest and to
or that or the supposedly conservative
party honest and to challenge them
they're getting dragged so far to the
left off the cliff that I don't know I
that certainly would not hurt her you
know in a Democratic primary in any way
whatsoever I do think that it might hurt
her in a general election I mean you
know a lot of what she said there it's
kind of hard not to conclude that she
hates America and if you hate our
borders and you hate are the laws
enforcing our borders then you kind of
by definition hate America and and and
that seems to be the campaign she's
running on and and then especially if
you know you think about running against
somebody like martha mcsalley who is a
at the very least has served her country
career military office and and and who's
made a joke of the fact that cinema
brags about having 100 pair of shoes and
mcsalley brags about 100 combat missions
whether you agree with those foreign
wars or not right and i have a real
problem with them whether you agree with
them or not the idea that you would
compare the the sacrifices that our men
and women have made in you know
following the orders of the military to
illegals crossing the border and dying
trying to break our laws and get into
the country it
astonishing it's pretty decadent and it
shows you how much Arizona has changed
because of absolutely Gration that she
has a shot charlie hurt thank you as
always I hope thank you